welcome back to Quantum Computing in practice I'm Olivia Lan and today's episode three is going to focus on a
qaoa experiment at the utility scale if you have been with us since the beginning you have seen us walk through
IBM Quantum Hardware the framework of Kiss kit patterns and the latest and greatest eror mitigation techniques that
researchers and developers use to scale up Quantum circuits we felt like it was really important to give you all this
context and show you the direction that we were headed but now there is no reason to wait any longer to see all of this information in
action now some things to keep in mind before we get started everything is going to follow the framework of Kiss
kit patterns so we will go through these steps in order number one is mapping the problem two optimizing the circuit three
executing with Primitives and four post-processing or analyzing the results we'll start with a fairly small example
so you can all best get a handle of these steps and their purpose then we will discuss a very similar but much
larger example to show you how one would scale up the problem to the 100 Cubit level I'm going to give you all the
tools to allow you to go forward after this lecture and run that problem independently last this is not going to
be a code walkthr no matter how hard we try as we make progress code gets old and becomes deprecated so if you end up
watching this video a year after it launches I don't want you to get hung up on the syntax that might slightly shift over time instead this will be a
detailed discussion of the logic and the problem statement however there is a notebook tutorial that pairs with this
video that is attached in the description below following along with the code or referring to it after you
watch this lesson and running it for yourself will give you the best possible learning experience so as a quick reminder not
all computational problems are suitable for Quantum Computing easy problems and simple calculations don't need to take
advantage of this technology because classical computers are perfectly good at solving them already as of 2024 the
three domains we are most optimistic about exploring are these simulating nature processing data with complex
structure and lastly optimization optimization problems are some of the toughest computational
problems to solve efficiently in an optimization problem you are looking for the largest or smallest possible value
for a given cost function however for many problems of Interest finding this extremum becomes exponentially more
difficult with the size of the problem that's why it becomes so hard to compute for an example you can imagine how
difficult it can be to compute optimal flight paths or delivery routes across the country in this lesson we are going
to explore a particular optimization problem called Max cut cut which we are going to solve by using a Quantum
algorithm called the quantum approximation optimization algorithm or qaoa so what is the max cut problem a
maximum cut problem is a type of combinatorial optimization problem defined on a graph where the goal is to
partition the vertices of the graph into two subsets such that the number of edges between the two subsets is
maximized so for instance in this graph here each node is connected like so and the max cut is shown by this squiggly
line which divides the nodes into the purple group and the gray group the way to do this by crossing the largest
number of edges possible is to cut through five edges for this graph here because the graph is so small
it isn't hard to try a few possible cuts on paper or even in your head and figure out that five is the best possible
option but imagine if the number of nodes doubled and then trip quickly this becomes impossible to do by
hand and after a certain number it becomes so tricky that even supercomputers struggle to reliably return the best answer this is because
the max number of cuts scales exponentially with the number of nodes while this may seem a bit abstract
there are many real world problems that can be cast into a Max cut problem such as fraud detection in finance graph
clustering Network design and VLS CL I design also social media analysis the
social media one is particularly easy to grasp say you want to find a group of individuals that have the most possible
connections to other individuals on a social media platform in order to identify power users or people who have
the most influence in a group companies actually try to do this quite frequently one last Point here the max cut is often
a sub routine of a bigger problem so it might not be defining the actual application but use under the hood it's
much more common than you might naively think now it is time to get started the
first step is to create our graph you can do this by importing a python package called rust Works Define how
many nodes you are working with by specifying the number n then add your nodes to the graph G you will also have
to draw your edges we'll do this by hand here by just listing them out in an array like this where you show the last
number which specifies the weight of the edge or how strongly the two nodes specified are connected here we're just
going to stick to a weight of one for all but you might enjoy playing around with the weight later on and seeing how the solution
changes to gain a sense of what weight means in this context let's go back to our social media example you can think
of this weight as how influential one person might be to another your connection to your spouse or relative
for instance would probably be given a higher weight than someone who is just an acquaintance now draw your graph the
tutorial attached will show you the proper syntax first before considering how to
map this problem onto a Quantum circuit let's build some context on how the max cut problem becomes an optimization
problem in the first place We Begin by first considering the minimization of a function f ofx where the put X is an
n-dimensional Vector whose components correspond to each node of the graph we will refer to this function from now on
as our cost function then we need to constrain each of these components to be either zero or
one here meaning on one side of the cut or the other we can write a function as
a pair of nodes x i and XJ which tells us whether the corresponding Edge is in the cut thus plus the quantity x i + XJ
minus x i XJ identifies whether the edge is in the cut if this quantity is equal
to one this implies that the edge is in the cut otherwise it is zero and the edge is not the problem of finding the
max number of edges in the cut can then be formulated as maximizing this function next we're actually going to
add a global minus sign to this function making the new problem equivalent to finding the minimum of this function